all right welcome to the program much to
discuss so let's get right into it
donald trump is starting to lose support
with
white voters this is the one demographic
group that at least
until recently donald trump still had
supporting him we looked at a cross
section of polling a couple of weeks ago
and we saw joe biden is winning the
black vote
joe biden is winning the latino vote joe
biden is winning women
joe biden is winning the college
educated however you want to slice and
dice it
donald trump's resistance line
demographically was
white voters particularly white men
particularly
uneducated white voters but
unfortunately
for trump good for the world donald
trump has lost
some ground with white voters relative
to 2016
and it could be could right depends on
who votes depends on whether votes are
counted properly
this could be trump's undoing in
november let's look at some numbers
in 2016 donald trump won
white voters in minnesota by seven and
right now trump is losing white voters
in minnesota by
two that's a nine-point swing
against trump among minnesota white
voters in wisconsin trump won
uneducated white women by 16
in the last election and he's now losing
uneducated white women
by nine that's a 25 point swing
against donald trump in pennsylvania
where we have a lot of data on this
biden and trump are tied among white
voters
trump won white voters in pennsylvania
in 2016.
but if you slice it down even further
donald trump is struggling with
pennsylvania
suburban white voters and this has been
a gradual shift
first it was the college-educated white
voters that started to move away from
donald trump
now you're even seeing non-college
educated white voters starting to move
away from donald trump now
to be fair and to be thorough there are
some other slices where trump has
improved since 2016 so
if you look at pennsylvania suburban
white women
trump's doing okay with them voters who
disliked
both trump and hillary in 2016 trump is
doing okay with them
but these are potentially significant
problems for donald trump again with a
major caveat
if everyone's votes are counted
now what's fascinating about this is
that as white voters have moved away
from donald trump
trump has been more and more
aggressively throwing out sort of like
red meat for white voters lately talking
about
saving the suburbs which has very
racially coded language
he's even lamented voters who have to
live around
refugees and immigrants in various parts
of the country he did that at a recent
i think it was pennsylvania and north
carolina rallies if i recall correctly
but regardless white voters slowly
moving away from donald trump now will
it be enough to make a difference
in the final calculation we don't know
we don't know
um the the the strategies that trump has
left to actually win
are dwindling one such strategy that
trump was hoping for was
announce a vaccine in october and
unfortunately for him two days ago the
federal
uh drug administration the fda uh said
that they are making uh putting in place
stricter guidelines to approve a vaccine
via an emergency use authorization
that's bad for trump
he's unlikely to get whatever boost he
might have gotten
from a vaccine announcement will trump
push for some emergency stimulus checks
right before the election i don't know
that he even has the time i really don't
particularly with the senate
uh going into recess and just what is it
about 21 days really just three weeks
so i don't know what trump can do and my
sense particularly from donald trump's
recent refusal to commit to a peaceful
transition of power if he loses
from donald trump's uh recent uh
revelation that we got
about a strategy to try to mess with the
electors
if he were to lose my instinct is
trump's focus
is no longer on actually winning it's on
having a strategy
to plausibly claim the results were
rigged and to
snatch the victory from joe biden if
joe biden were to win today one of our
sponsors
is surf shark which is a premium vpn
service
they're giving my audience 83 off a
two-year plan
plus three extra months for free coming
out in total to about
two bucks a month it's 2020 if you're
not already using a vpn
now is the time to start vpns hide your
ip address online
protects you from government
surveillance big tech companies
can't track you online and internet
service providers won't be able to log
and sell your internet history surf
shark is the vpn i trust because they
don't monitor or log your internet
activity like many other vpns do
it encrypts your data you can install it
on unlimited devices
it can block ads protect you from
malware and fishing
and it even lets you stream tv shows and
movies
that are only available in other
countries surf shark is giving my
audience
83 off a two-year plan plus
three extra month free so that comes out
to just about two dollars a month which
is
almost nothing relative to the peace of
mind you will have while browsing online
just go to surfshark.deals
pacman i've put the link underneath this
video and make sure to use the coupon
code pacman